hi there steve kaufman here
um i finally went out and bought another
version
of imovie since my previous ones stopped
working for me and i got tired of
not knowing which one of my videos would
survive without crashing
uh
apple annoys me to be honest they have
some very creative stuff but i think the
quality of a lot of their products
leaves a lot to be desired
i hope someone else comes along and
takes their
takes some of their products and and
makes it better and cheaper
uh every time i have a problem i have to
phone and pay money for tech support it
really it really does annoy me
um
yeah i want to talk a little bit about
what i consider to be one important
aspect of language learning
and that is to uh
to stay relaxed
uh to stay relaxed you know i was on uh
on a forum amongst english teachers and
they're talking about uh
trying to hide that light that's by my
head there anyways
um
you know the importance of paris
segmentals
in teaching english pronunciation what
is a parasegmental i mean it's some term
that refers to the fact that
that
in the pronunciation of any language
including english
uh there's intonation there's stress
there's sounds that carry on into the
next word from the previous word
and we can try and define and explain
all these things but the fact the matter
is you have to listen you have to listen
very carefully in order to get these
things
and and i think the big thing in
language learning is
the new language anyone who's starting
for the first time a new language is
different
it's different it won't be easy at first
it sounds strange the sounds are strange
they sound like a blur you think they're
speaking too quickly they're not
and the structure is different
and and yet
you know some of the
grammar concepts are really there's not
that many of them
uh you have to deal with with nouns with
things how do people describe things
some languages have
uh gender others don't
in some languages we use prepositions so
that it's to the place from the place by
the person of the person so that we have
little
prepositions before the word
in other languages they have cases so
that the noun changes depending on
whether it's by to from of in ad
and some languages have both
prepositions
and case endings
so you know don't be surprised if you
come to a language where the words
change now trying to remember all the
prepositions and trying to remember all
of the endings is very difficult and it
takes a long time and it takes a lot of
exposure but there's you don't need a
lot of detailed explanation you have to
figure out early on
whether uh in this language the
sort of key helper words come before the
noun or after the noun
uh the same with verbs i mean in some
languages like japanese and korean
a lot of things happen at the end of the
now so in order to because
uh and and so forth
these words don't appear or therefore
they don't appear as separate words
before the verb
they show up after the word verb and so
you get used to finding them there
uh
some languages have complex tenses like
english
other languages don't
um
you know uh
you have to figure out how the
adjectives and adverbs work
um you have to figure out how to ask
questions
and how to say how the negative works
but that's about all there is
how do their nouns work
and their pronouns like some languages
like chinese it's the same pronoun
whether it's to me from me i
i go you give to me it's all the same
it's one pronoun very easy and the nouns
don't change so that's pretty
straightforward but they have other
things that are different and so every
language is different you have in
russian where you say i have something
you don't say i have you say to me is to
me is that's how they say it
uh
you know in english we say my name is
steve
in french they say i call myself steve
in russian they say they call me steve
okay
uh you've gotta be flexible
i remember very well i worked studying
chinese with a canadian who very early
said
chinese is stupid
because they say you will not go meaning
are you going you go not go
not stupid it's no more stupid than uh
are you going
uh
in some languages they invert the order
verb and uh
and you know the the subject
uh to mean that to imply that it's a
question other languages don't uh the
chinese go you're gonna go
there's so many different ways that
humans
have come up with to convey meaning and
the important thing is to be relaxed
uh be open to the new way don't resist
it don't fight it
recognize that it's
strange to your brain
it's a different approach therefore it's
going to take your brain a while
to get used to it and that the best way
to get used to it is to expose yourself
to a lot of the language by listening
and reading you can read the
explanations and the explanations are
everywhere they can be found in the
little book
you can find them on the internet
uh we are going to introduce more
explanation at link
but the explanation doesn't do it if it
was merely a matter of explanation
all the people who study languages to
school where they get all these
explanations uh they would all leave
school uh fluent in whatever language
they're studying but that's not the case
and so the key thing is to be open
relaxed
don't expect to learn anything the first
time you study it
be prepared for the fact that you need
to spend a lot of time
you want to learn the language and you
listen to the language and you don't get
frustrated when you forget and you don't
get frustrated when you don't understand
you don't get frustrated when the
structure is completely foreign to you
the way you are used the way your brain
is used to
dealing with language bear in mind that
somebody else's brain
the brain of the native speaker of that
language is structured in such a way
that this is normal
and you can train your own brain
to find these new structures normal it's
just a question of time you don't need
any special talent
you don't need any special teacher
you just need to be open-minded
and expose yourself enough to it and pay
attention to what's happening and
certainly reading and regularly
reviewing grammar rules can help you
notice what's happening because
sometimes you just don't notice
but more than that and most of the time
needs to be spent on listening and
reading and the more interesting the
stuff you're listening to the more
likely you're continuing your you are to
continue doing it and the more likely
you are to like the language to enjoy it
and therefore
your brain is now positive there's
positive positive chemicals charging
around in your brain you're more likely
to pick it up so make the language
learning an enjoyable experience be
open-minded stay cool don't resist the
language recognize that when it comes to
pronoun basically grammar boils down to
pronouns or nouns pronouns verbs
adjectives and adverbs period and how
people ask questions and how they
differentiate between differentiate
between yes and no and you get those few
concepts down in the language you're off
and running so there you have it just
some very
general advice
for people who are starting into
language learning it really isn't all
that difficult
thank you